[Musique]
elle est une affaire de détournement par
mx d'un avion de la rai nerfs et
l'arrestation d'un journaliste à bord le
président russe vladimir poutine a reçu
son homologue biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko une rencontre à sotchi au
lendemain de l'ouverture d'une enquête
par l' agence ou d'hygiène de l'aviation
civile dans mon la foulée du rwanda
emmanuel macron est en visite en afrique
du sud où il est arrivé ce matin
l'escale centrée sur la lutte contre le
colis de 19 et la crise économique
provoquée par la pandémie et il s'est
entretenu à pretoria avec son homologue
cyril ramaphosa qui demandent la levée
des brevets sur les vaccins pour
permettre aux africains de produire et
de se faire vacciner massivement et puis
l'allemagne a reconnu avoir commis un
génocide en libye pendant l'ère
coloniale berlin demande pardon aux
descendants des victimes issues des
populations héréros et namas et s'engage
à verser plus d'un milliard d'euros
dette au pays
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france est la russie
tente de calmer le jeu après le
détournement d'un vol civil par la
biélorussie l affaire remonte à dimanche
outre le déroutage d'un avion de la
ryanair minsk a procédé à l'arrestation
d'un journaliste à bord et vladimir
poutine s'est entretenu aujourd'hui à
sotchi avec son homologue biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko
l'objectif désamorcer les tensions avec
l'union européenne notamment en réaction
elle et 27 ont demandé à leurs
compagnies de contourner l'espace aérien
biélorusse est ce la craie la pagaille
comme par exemple l'annulation de deux
vols d'air france paris moscou ont fait
le point avec notre correspondant à
moscou antoine cléroux bien entendu
cette rencontre était attendu à la
lumière des récents événements
impliquant le vol dérouté par les
autorités biélorusses et ses
conséquences en termes de trafic aérien
et d'éventuelles sanctions président
biélorusse s'est présenté face à son
homologue avec près de lui une mallette
qui d'après lui contiennent des
documents censés apporter des preuves à
la position du ministre alexandre
loukachenko qui a au passage accusé
l'occident de chercher à déstabiliser
son pays à dire poutine de son côté a
rappelé le précédent de l'avion
présidentiel bolivien qui en 2013 a été
forcé de se poser à vienne sous la
pression des états unis de crainte qu
edward ce modèle se trouve à bord je
vous propose d'écouter les deux hommes
je vais vous présenter un certain nombre
de documents et vous allez voir ce qui
se passe cette chaude c'est une
tentative de et des salaires qu'ils
avaient détourné l'avion de président
bolivien ben oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
et est un tueur qui vous souvenez de
cela un avion qui
dirigés vers sydney et on a fait
atterrir l'avion
d'accord c'est votre droit a sauvé rente
de la faire il a donc été question de
l'actualité de ce vol dérouté donc mais
pas seulement le développement des
relations bilatérales et de
l'intégration des deux pays étaient
également au programme de cette
rencontre
d'ailleurs à ce sujet vladimir poutine a
fait l'éloge de résultats concrets du
rapprochement entre la russie et la
biélorussie
après le rwanda l'afrique du sud
emmanuel macron est arrivée à pretoria
ce matin déplacement initialement prévu
liens non mais reporté à cause de la
pandémie
une visite consacrée à la lutte contre
le colis de 19 et son impact sur
l'économie sud-africaine en berne
l occasion de parler vaccination avec
son homologue sur place cyril ramaphosa
qui demandent la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins pour permettre au continent
d'accélérer la cadence et nos présidents
elle français s'y est montré une
nouvelle fois favorable je vous propose
de les écouter sur le principe de lever
les contraintes de la propriété
intellectuelle pour permettre la
production en afrique et partout dans le
monde
nous sommes pour ce que nous avons
besoin de faire c'est de vacciner le
plus vite possible le maximum de gens et
on a besoin de couvrir le plus de nos
populations partout dans le monde
c'est un devoir moral de solidarité de
faire à l'égard des pays à revenu
intermédiaire où les pays les plus
pauvres et 7
si je puis dire et je rappellerai tout à
l'heure une exigence d'efficacité
les pays qui ont le plus besoin de
vaccin n'en n'ont pas et sur le
continent africain
ils ne sont que 2 % à avoir été vaccinée
comparé aux autres pays
les etats-unis sont à environ 40% et
d'autres au même niveau et le réel défi
que nous rencontrons est d'avoir la
vaccination les pays les plus développés
possède ces vaccins et les gardent pour
eux nous sommes coincés pour plusieurs
raisons mais le plus important
et d'avoir accès à la vaccination
maintenant on en vient au mea culpa de
l'allemagne envers son ex colonie la
namibie elle a reconnu aujourd'hui avoir
perpétrer un génocide contre les hereros
c est la masse pendant l'ère coloniale
berlin va payer aux pays plus d'un
milliard d'euros dette selon un accord
de réconciliation considérée comme un
pas dans la bonne direction la vallée
précision et avec amaya soubelet l'heure
est à la reconnaissance
cette semaine après la france c'est au
tour de l'allemagne de prendre ses
responsabilités à propos d'une tragédie
qui s'est déroulée en afrique par la
voix de son ministre des affaires
étrangères berlin a reconnu son rôle
dans le génocide en namibie ce
territoire africain a été colonisée par
l'allemagne entre 1884 et 1915 au début
du 20e siècle
deux tribus autochtones les héréros et
namas sont victimes des massacres de
masse au total ce sont près de 10000
nama et 60000 herrero qui ont été tués
par des colons allemands nous
qualifierons maintenant officiellement
ces événements course qu'ils ont été un
génocide
ce faisant nous reconnaissons également
notre responsabilité historique
même les cheveux des à la lumière de la
responsabilité historique et morale de
l'allemagne nous allons demander pardon
à la namibie et aux descendants des
victimes
selon le porte parole du président
namibien
cette décision est de bon augure pour
les relations entre les deux pays
l'acceptation de la part de l'allemagne
qu'un génocide a été commis est un
premier pas dans la bonne direction
le chef de la diplomatie allemande a
ensuite annoncé soutenir la
reconstruction et le développement de la
namibie à l'aide d'un programme
financier de 1,1 milliard d'euros une
somme qui sera versée sur une période de
30 ans et qui devrait en priorité
profiter aux descendants des deux
populations touchées par ce génocide
depuis de nombreuses années le
gouvernement namibien demandé
des excuses officielles ainsi que des
réparations une requête jusqu'ici
refusée par l'allemagne qui évoqué
notamment l'aide financière versée au
pays depuis son indépendance en 1990 en
france maintenant aujourd'hui une
attaque au couteau près de nantes la
policière 10 et survivre à ses blessures
selon les mots du ministre de
l'intérieur elle a été agressée par un
homme dans les locaux de la police
municipale à la chapelle-sur-erdre le
suspect a été tué lors d'échangés de
tirs avec la police au moins deux
gendarmes ont été blessés lors de
l'opération est pour l'heure on ne
connaît pas les motivations de
l'assaillant qui aurait agi délibérément
contre les forces de l'ordre
écoutez gérald darmanin à 9h45 un
individu s'est présenté au poste de
police municipale de la commune et a
agressé sauvagement au couteau une
policière municipale qui heureusement
manifestement survivre à ses blessures
et qui évidemment nous pensons
manifestement l'auteur souhaitait
agressé des gendarmes et et je confirme
effectivement à l'hyper proximité des
brigades de gendarmerie cet auteur c'est
manifestement réfugiés après avoir été
délogés par les gendarmes dont
j'expliquais tout à l'heure qu'ils
avaient été extrêmement efficace pour
repéré l'individu
il sait il les a agressées en tirant sur
eux et les gendarmes ont riposté et dans
ce contexte se profilent les élections
régionales dans 23 jours à paris et en
ile de france est l'occasion pour le
parti socialiste menée par audrey pulvar
de monter au créneau
la tête de liste dans les yvelines appel
à une alternative réelle dans la région
écouter
dieynaba diop il est temps d'avoir une
alternative à la politique qui est menée
par valérie pécresse c'est à dire une
région plus juste qui soutient qui agite
mais qui aussi beaucoup plus solidaire
nous avons aussi fait le choix d'avoir
des mesures concrètes qui répondent aux
aspirations quotidiennes des franciliens
et j'en veux pour preuve notre mesure
phare qui essaient de la gratuité des
transports
on sait très bien que dans cette période
de crise il faut une mesure d'écologie
sociale c'est ce que nous proposons avec
une mesure qui est aussi bonne pour le
pouvoir d'achat que pour l'environnement
il est temps et avec audrey pulvar avec
les 225 candidates et candidats
nous pouvons le faire et nous le ferons
avec où on l'a appris aujourd'hui le
régulateur européen a approuvé l'usagé
du vaccin files heures biotech pour les
12 15 ans à l'europe ont rejoint ainsi
de nombreux pays qui vaccinent déjà à
partir de 12 ans et puis le directeur
europe de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé dénonce justement le rythme
vaccinale encore trop lent en europe il
se dit inquiet face aux nouveaux
variants notamment indiens
beaucoup plus virulent est propice à la
propagation en cette période où de
nombreux pays ceux des confine seule
solution selon lui vacciner au moins 70
% de la population mondiale
je vous propose de l'écouter je
m'inquiète surtout de deux choses de la
première concerne les inquiétants
nouveaux variants nous conservons par
exemple que le variant b 1617 identifié
d'abord en inde et plus contagieux que
le bis 117 identifié d'abord au royaume
uni ils étaient déjà plus contagieux que
la souche précédent et se danse de
priver de la pandémie sera terminée
lorsque nous aurons atteint une
couverture vaccinale minimal de 70%
isaac signifie et l'initiative kovacs
lancé en février dernier par un logo msc
face à de nombreuses difficultés imaginé
comme une solution basée sur la
solidarité des pays riches pour les pays
les plus démunis
le projet doit permettra d'augmenter de
façon significative la couverture
vaccinale dans le monde mais
l'initiative peine à se mettre en place
on voit cela avec ton abonnés
dans cette course folle au vaccin il a
été assez rapidement établi qu'il ne
fallait pas laisser les pays l'est
plus pauvres sur le bord de la route en
février le ms lançait donc kovacs un
dispositif visant à partager les doses
de vaccins avec les pays les plus
démunis
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
expliquant qu une large couverture
vaccinale permettrait de diminuer
l'impact de la pandémie notamment sur
les personnels de santé
au départ les pays riches devaient
partager des doses mais rapidement les
dons sont devenus financiers les limites
industriels ont poussé les pays qui le
pouvaient à se garantir un accès
prioritaire aux vaccins disponibles
une course contre la montre qui a mis un
coup d'arrêt aux élan solidaire de
kovacs autre coup du sort pour
l'initiative
l'émergence du variant indien il se
trouve que c'est en inde qui étaient
fabriqués les doses destinées à kovacs
face à la situation dans le pays
le gouvernement indien a décidé de les
garder pour ses habitants
résultat les chiffres de kovacs son
trésor dessous des attentes
l'augmentation soudaine des cas a
compromis une aide globale de vaccins et
il y a déjà un manque de 190 millions de
doses kovacs d'ici la fin du mois de
juin mme kovacs works kovacs fonctionne
et a déjà délivré 65 millions de doses à
124 pays jusque là mais il est dépendant
des pays et des usines honorant leurs
engagements un appel entendu est partagé
par trois patrons de laboratoires tels
que pfizer bio ntech moderna ou encore
johnson & johnson
dans ses messages vidéo il appelle à la
solidarité et promettent des millions
voire des milliards
dos à venir pour les pays les plus
pauvres aujourd'hui files heures et bio
ntech s'engage à fournir 2 milliards de
doses de notre vaccin contre le coc vide
19 aux pays à faibles revenus d'ici les
18 prochains mois
max sauf qu'en plus de la difficile mise
en place de la solidarité la logistique
n'est pas non plus irréprochable face à
la concurrence et devant la difficulté
de passer des contrats
kovacs doit souvent se contenter des
restes obtenant des dates de livraison
éloigné certaine dose n'arriveront pas
avant 2022
quant à celles qui arrivent à
destination elles ne connaissent pas
forcément un best un heureux non plus au
malawi par exemple vingt mille doses
d'astrazeneca ont été incinérés les
doses ayant dépassé leur date
d'expiration
un cas loin d'être isolé puisqu'il ya
quelques jours le soudan du sud a
affirmé qu'il allait renvoyer 72 mille
doses de vaccin astrazeneca a kovacs le
gouvernement estime ne pas être en
mesure de les distribuer avant leur date
d'expiration
il faut dire qu'en plus des problèmes
logistiques la méfiance est grande en
afrique contre ces campagnes de
vaccination les autorités font face au
scepticisme d'une partie de la
population face à ces vaccins
alors même si les pays riches une fois
leur population largement vacciner se
décide à aider les plus pauvres
les campagnes de vaccination dans ces
pays risquent de se confronter à de
nombreuses difficultés
écoutez à ce propos richard cojean et
les médecins anesthésistes réanimateurs
président de l' ong à lima selon lui
justement il dénonce c'est bien le
manque de soutien des plus riches
au programme à kovacs c'est un beau
programme qui des vrais et qui devrait
apporter qui détecte monde qui est
répondre aux objectifs dès le départ
mais bon c'est un programme un programme
nécessite un support derrière et c'est
super derrière des vrais venir de
notamment des des bienfaiteurs des
volontaires
les pays riches n'ont pas que des pays
riches mais aussi des privés riches dont
on va faire en sorte que ces programmes
d kovacs fonctionne et est rentré à
danser dans ses objectifs
le programme kovacs devait aller au delà
des dans son support devrait aller au
delà des programmes nationale
c'est-à-dire venir en support aux
programmes nationaux mais les
accompagner au délà pas seulement le
fait de drop télémaque sont locaux vides
19 at il été créé en laboratoire une
question qui pourra de nouveau être
posée sur facebook sa théorie rejetée
par à la communauté scientifique était
jusqu alors bannie du réseau social mais
depuis que le président américain joe
biden a chargé les services de
renseignement d'enquêter sur le sujet
facebook fait machine arrière
les explications c'est avec calme at-il
de romagne rétropédalage de facebook sur
la question d'une origine humaine du
coronavirus jusqu'à présent tous les
messages allant dans le sens de cette
théorie était banni du réseau social
c'est le cas également pour les
allégations sur la prétendue
l'inefficacité des vaccins ou sur leur
caractère soi-disant toxiques et
dangereux par exemple à la lumière des
investigations en cours sur les origines
du coc vite 19 et en consultation avec
les experts de la santé
nous ne retirerons désormais plus de nos
plateformes les allégations sur le fait
que le coït 19 a été créée par l'homme
ou a été fabriqué ce message a été
publié quelques heures après l annonce
du président américain joe biden qui
demande une nouvelle enquête sur
l'origine du virus
mercredi il a appelé les services de
renseignement américains à redoubler
d'efforts pour expliquer l'origine de la
pandémie
sans écarter aucune piste dont celle de
l'origine humaine
cette volte face montre la difficulté de
facebook à trouver un équilibre entre
liberté d'expression et modération
le réseau social par nécessité
économique et politique tente d'apaiser
des échanges parfois empreint de
harcèlement de fausses rumeurs ou de
théories du complot
aux etats unis comme en france facebook
est souvent critiquée par les élus
politiques
inquiet du pouvoir détenu par le groupe
californien difficile pour le réseau
social d'arbitrer le débat public en
étant accusé par les seins de censure et
par les autres de propager la
désinformation en comparaison twitter
youtube ou google n'ont pas les mêmes
politiques de régulation youtube par
exemple autorise la publication de
différentes théories sur l'origine du
virus car il n'y a pas de consensus sur
ce sujet selon la plateforme
le service de vidéo de google surveille
lui les théories conspirationnistes liés
à la pandémie
on en parle tout de suite avec un tony
benn il est avocat spécialiste du
numérique à bonsoir à vous merci d'être
en direct avec quotient arte france
pourquoi cette volte face du réseau
social qui censurait jusqu'au là on l'a
dit les messages sont les origines
prétendu le collier de 19 volte-face de
la porte de facebook en effet et qobuz
elle revient en réalité à la position
qu'a van houtte et facebook à l'origine
c'est-à-dire à l'origine de la
réglementation juridique de la
responsabilité des uns et des réseaux
sociaux comme facebook c'est à dire que
ils ne sont qu elle berges du contenu à
partir du moment où les réseaux sociaux
ne sont pas hauteur de toutes les
publications sur le réseau qui sont
faites par les utilisateurs le droit
considère son hébergeur c'est à dire
qu'il n'engage pas leurs responsabilités
et à partir du moment où ils n'engagent
pas leurs responsabilités n'ont pas mené
en place les moyens humains et
techniques pour contrôler tout ce qui
était un contenu illicite ou provocation
à la haine antisémite raciste et notre
avec cetera aujourd'hui depuis quelques
temps facebook fait des annonces de
manière politique pour dire qu'il va
contrôler les contenus en réalité je
pense que facebook ne contrôle pas tant
de choses que cela est une nouvelle
surprend guère que facebook décide
aujourd'hui de revenir sur sa position à
savoir de ne plus contrôler les
informations qui sont déserts fox des
mauvaises informations ou des
informations de théories du complot sur
le gobi en tout cas la décision de
facebook intervient après l'annoncé
joe biden on l'a vu sur une enquête ça
démontre quoi
ça démontre qu'en réalité facebook
finalement eu baisse les armes et décide
de manière assez facile de ne rien
contrôler car c'est plus facile pour le
réseau de deux rencontres les plutôt que
de mettre moins en oeuvre les moyens
techniques et humains pour filtrer les
informations qui sont diffusés chaque
jour sur le réseau tout en sachant qu'il
faut faire très attention car on parle
de millions d'informations chaque jour
et que donc même avec des moyens humains
il sera impossible de contrôler toutes
les informations alors est ce que cette
décision elle est conforme à la
politique réglementaire de la plateforme
est-ce que d'une certaine façon cela ne
risque pas de remettre en cause le
respect des normes au sort du réseau
social alors le réseau social facebook
comme twitter ou les autres finalement
modifié au gré du temps leurs conditions
générales et imposent leurs conditions
générales aux utilisateurs le service
est gratuit et en contrepartie les
utilisateurs acceptent ne lis même pas
les conditions générales et cette
volte-face de facebook s'agissant des
1,6 sur le corps vide de l'information
telle théorie du complot du comique au
vide
finalement des montres démontré qu'à moi
facebook elle finalement refuse de
contrôler et puis aussi surtout est
incapable de contrôler les informations
qui sait que ce soit et à votre avis
quelle quel message
comment cela est perçu par les
utilisateurs
bon je pense que depuis le début les
utilisateurs ne sont pas dupes savoir
que facebook ne contrôle pas de ne
contrôle rien et donc en réalité le fait
que facebook aujourd'hui revienne sur sa
position il décide de ne purent et
contrôler s'agissant de sa fonction
locaux vides ne doit pas l'air que les
utilisateurs du chapeau je pense
personne ne surprend pas non plus est ce
que ça peut tourner à l'avantagé de
twitter ou encore de youtube je ne pense
pas que les utilisateurs des réseaux
sociaux recherche de la moralité
réseau ils cherchent chacun cherche le
réseau pour ce qu'il est à savoir un
support de communication un média et
finalement il ne revient pas forcément
aux médias de d'âge et kt et de la
morale de l'équité et peut-être qu'un
jour ce sera le cas mais aujourd'hui
facebook et twitter et les autres
bénéficient d'une absence de
réglementation ce qui fait qu'en réalité
ils peuvent varier leur fusil d'épaulé
au gré de leurs envies comme il le
souhaite
et encore cette dernière question
finalement est ce que les états ont leur
mot à dire notamment en europe
lawler en effet en europe depuis
quelques années l'europe et essaye de se
doter d'un arsenal juridique pour tenter
de responsabiliser les sites les réseaux
sociaux le problème c'est que l'europe
est faible voire fragiles face aux
sociétés privées de droits américains
tels que facebook ou twitter ou le droit
européen n'a pas beaucoup d'application
on sait que ce sont des sociétés soumis
au droit américain
de sorte que le droit européen ne
s'applique pas peut-être que demain il y
aura des sanctions qui seront des
sanctions dont financière et qui feront
que les réseaux sociaux aux etats unis
seront obligés de se conformer au droit
européen mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le cas et je crains que dans les années
à venir
les sites internet et aux etats unis
bénéficient d'un paravent d'une
protection grâce aux dons américains au
premier un moment de sorte que le noir
aucun malheureusement de pouvoir réunir
merci beaucoup à vous entonnez belge
rappelle que vous êtes avocat
spécialiste du numérique
dans l'actualité internationale le
lancement de la campagne pour la
présidentielle iranienne
aujourd'hui sept candidats vont
s'affronter pour un scrutin prévu le 18
juin parmi eux 7 5
ultra conservateur et un favori qui
semblent se détacher une partie de
l'opposition appellent au boycott mais
de son côté l'ayatollah ali khamenei il
exhorte le peuple à ne pas l'écouter on
fait le point avec julien duroux à la
proche de la présidentielle le climat
dans l'ancienne perse semble plus axé
sur la défiance que sur la confiance et
les appels au boycott se multiplient en
cause l'invalidation de plusieurs
centaines de candidatures
ce qui laisse le champ quasi libre aux
ultra-conservateurs qui sont au nombre
de 5 sur les sept n'ont qu'a retenue le
conseil des gardiens de la constitution
parmi les premiers à approuver ces
disqualifications
l'ayatollah ali khamenei appelle le
peuple iranien de se rendre aux urnes
deux à trois semaines du scrutin
j'espère vivement qu'avec les efforts du
peuple iranien
cette élection qui va à l'encontre de la
volonté de l'ennemi préservera la
réputation de l'iran nos ennemis ainsi
que les gens à l'intérieur du pays qui
sciemment ou non
relais leurs paroles utilisent tous les
moyens pour que cette élection mène à la
défaite de la nation iranienne
j'espère que le peuple fera un effort et
que dieu tout puissant le bénir à pour
que cette élection soit une source de
fierté et d'honneur pour le pays
les rejets des candidatures du
conservateur ali larijani du populiste
mahmoud ahmadinejad et du réformateur et
chaque jean-guy ont le plus fait réagir
au lendemain de cette décision le
président roagna annoncé avoir écrit au
guide suprême mercredi à ce lundi matin
nous avons été informés de la décision
du respectable conseil des gardiens est
dans la soirée son choix est devenu
clair s'agissant des candidats que ses
membres retenus
en fait de nombreux hommes politiques
dont nous-mêmes souhaité un cas de
figure où le conseil des gardiens
accorderait plus de candidatures mais le
conseil voulait une configuration qui
représentent le fondement électorale de
l'iran
la variété d'une élection réside dans la
compétition que les candidats se livrent
si vous enlevez l'âme d'une élection
elle devient un corps sans vie
c'est donc sa vraie nature
désormais souhaitons une compétition
acharnée pour aboutir à une véritable
élection en iran la crise économique et
sociale suscite une grande colère parmi
la population
pour hassan droy nier son gouvernement
la solution à ses problèmes réside dans
les négociations de l'accord de vienne
sur le nucléaire et un retour des états
unis à la table des négociations
les conservateurs quant à eux accusent
le président de la république islamique
d'imputer ces difficultés à l'occident
tout en ne permettant pas aux pays de
surpasser les sanctions de washington dc
au 18 juin la campagne présidentielle
pourrait bien réserver des surprises de
taille et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vos de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en direct dans 30 minutes
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]